seven and two coming off
a start where he did not strike out
anyone
and there is
a strikeout
after a couple of pitches out of the
strike zone
two strikeouts in two at bats have the
same pitch
how about that didn't strike anybody out
in five innings in chicago and he
strikes out the side
on the ground second base lori garcia
throws out cruz and the innings over six
up six down through one
in the
zach is now suddenly for the next month
and change the sox number one catcher
zach into center field that is a hit and
it gives the sox the lead by a pair two
two-run hit for zach collins
in this second inning that is just a
huge hit because it looked like you're
coming away empty in this inning and
instead
sucks on top two to nothing
driven to the right field corner
and down for a hit jeffers rounding
second on his way to third
and he'll be held there and kepler
drives a double into the corner
and the twins are in business
three and two
he went with a change up rodon stabs it
tags sano and gets out number two
3-2
it's a fastball it's lined to right and
it's adam eaton to make the catch and
rodon works his way through
two on with one out
socks up two
that second hop
to polanco but he stayed with it barrios
has a quick 123 inning
strike three on a changeup for rodon his
second strike out of the ball game
slider locked him up strike three
two strikeouts looking in the inning for
carlos rodon
to third johan across the way on the
feed to a break you easy does it for
carlos one two three third socks by a
pair
two hopper the rise goes the short way
and that closes out the top of the
fourth
[Music]
to lap
and down for a hit kiriloff continues to
hit
and continues to hit left-handed
pitching i asked taco baldelli today
about carol off and not only he's in the
is he in the lineup against lefties but
he's hitting cleanup kirill off at first
he holds and that's strike three that's
a fastball right there
and jefferson packing
there's another slider
in the air to the outfield in right and
eaton makes the catch to secure round
number three we'll go to the fifth row
don shutting out the twins and it's soon
i think socks lead
and inside gets a swing of the miss
wow another swinging strikeout we call
that a swinging strikeout that was a
brilliant swing
one and two
sharply hit simmons knocks it down comes
up firing good play by the twin
shortstop
and he gets a round of applause from his
pitcher
trail to center
and cenos aboard with a lead off symbol
first time the twins have had a lead off
man on and that'll bring up celestino
he got him out to get out of the second
inning another big pitch
home quickly moncada garcia that is a
double play five and four and three
euan took his time and made a perfect
throw and then leary garcia on the back
end
put it away for two and that means
somebody gets another warranty
strike three
carlos just turned simmons into a
pretzel
and a quick strikeout of a break won
three pitches
eight strikeouts by burrills
and everyone has been swinging
six really good innings for jose barrels
with nine swinging strikeouts yet the
twins trail dude another
[Music]
deflected off of radon's glove and
that'll put a rise at first base
it would have gone straight to mendic
for a routine out instead it's an
infield head here's cruz a couple of
ground outs
on the second one to short
a towering fly into the twilight
i don't think they see it goodwin
doesn't see it
and now the ball will drop
a pop fly single now twilight can be a
tricky time anyway
but it this literally disappeared into
the clouds
such low-hanging clouds here tonight and
it looked as if that ball actually went
up
into the clouds yeah the two men are on
hiro off the batter singleton left his
last time up
up the middle of the base hit
a rise around third he'll be waved home
kiriloff comes through again and the
twins are on the board crews advances to
third on the rbi single by kerala
yeah the twins have gotten themselves
some player right here that's a breaking
ball down but didn't try to pull it
right back up the middle and nelson
legging it for third
makes it easily
here's atomy in a driving range yeah
infield in at all four positions big at
bat
right side through
there is your run it's three to one adam
eaton on the first pitch he sees a base
hit to right and the socks are up too
that's a huge run bad and then it's
number 28.
strike three four straight strikeouts
for liam hendricks in the drenching
reign
who needs eye drops
1-0
into center field hamilton
whoa
a make your own slip and slide for billy
hamilton
come on
like it's his back yard
that is
unreal
well first of all you're getting some
awful footing and second of all he gets
a great break on this ball and somehow
runs it down
a full out dive and goes into the wall
and catches the ball what a play that is